so our setup is that we have some kind
of two variable function f x y who has a
scalar output and the goal is to
approximate it near a specific input
point and this is something i've already
talked about in the context of a local
linearization and i've written out the
full local line
the full local linearization hard words
to say local linearization in its most
abstract and general form and it looks
like quite the beast but once you
actually break it apart which i'll do in
a moment it's it's not actually that bad
and the goal of this video is going to
be to extend this idea and it'll
literally be just adding terms onto this
formula to get a quadratic approximation
and what that means is we're starting to
allow ourselves to use terms like x
squared x times y
and y squared and quadratic basically
just means anytime you have two
variables multiplied together so here
you have two x's multiplied together
here it's an x multiplied with a y and
here y squared that kind of thing
so let's take a look at this local
linearization it seems like a lot but
once you actually kind of go through
term by term
you realize it's a relatively simple
function and if you were to plug in
numbers for the constant terms it would
come out as something relatively simple
because this right here where you're
evaluating the function at the specific
input point that's just going to be some
kind of constant that's just going to
output some kind of number and similarly
when you do that to the the partial
derivative this little f sub x means
partial derivative at that point you're
just getting another number and over
here this is also just another number
but we've written it in the abstract
form so that
you can see what you would need to plug
in for any function and for any possible
input point and the reason for having it
like this the reason that it comes out
to this form is because of a few
important properties that this
linearization has let me move this stuff
out of the way we'll get back to it in a
moment
but i just want to emphasize a few
properties that this has because it's
going to be properties that we want our
quadratic approximation to have as well
first of all when you actually evaluate
this function
at the desired point at x not y naught
what do you get
well this constant term isn't influenced
by the variables so you'll just get that
f evaluated at those points
x naught y naught
and now the rest of the terms when we
plug in x here this is the only place
where you actually see the variable
maybe that's worth pointing out right
we've got two variables here and there's
a lot going on but the only places where
you actually see those variables show up
where you have to plug in anything
is over here and over here when you plug
in x naught for our initial input this
entire term goes to zero right
and then similarly when you plug in y
naught over here
this entire term is going to go to 0
which multiplies out to 0 for everything
so what you end up with you don't have
to add anything else this is just a fact
and this is an important fact because it
tells you your
your approximation for the function at
the point about which you are
approximating actually equals the value
of the function at that point so that's
very good but we have a couple other
important facts also because this isn't
just a constant approximation this is
doing a little bit more for us if you
were to take the partial derivative of
this linearization with respect to x
what do you get
what do you get when you actually take
this partial derivative
well if you look up at the original
function this constant term is nothing
so that just corresponds to a zero
over here this entire thing looks like a
constant multiplied by x minus something
and if you differentiate this with
respect to x what you're going to get is
that constant term which is the partial
derivative of f evaluated
at our our specific point
and then the other term has no x's in it
it's just a y which as far as x
concerned is a constant so this whole
thing would be zero which means the
partial derivative with respect to x is
equal to
the value of the partial derivative of
our original function with respect to x
at that point now notice this is not
saying that our linearization has the
same partial derivative as f everywhere
it's just saying that its partial
derivative happens to be a constant and
the constant that it is is the value of
the partial derivative of f at that
specific input point and you can do
pretty much the same thing and you'll
you'll see that the partial derivative
of the linearization with respect to y
is a constant and the constant that it
happens to be is the value of the
partial derivative of f evaluated at
that desired point so these are three
facts you know the value of the
linearization at the point and the value
of its two different partial derivatives
and these kind of define the
linearization itself now what we're
going to do for the quadratic
approximation is take this entire
formula and i'm just literally going to
copy it here and then we're going to add
to it so that the second partial
differential information of our
approximation matches that of the
original function okay that's kind of a
mouthful but it'll become clear as i
actually as i actually work it out
and let me just kind of clean it up at
least a little bit here
so what we're going to do is we're going
to extend this and i'm going to change
its name because i don't want it to be a
linear function anymore what i want is
for this to be a quadratic function so
instead i'm going to call it q of x y
and now we're going to add some terms
and what i could do what i could do is
add you know a constant times x squared
since that's something we're allowed
plus some kind of constant times x y
and then another constant times y
squared
but the problem there is that if i just
add these as they are then it might mess
things up when i plug in x naught and y
naught right it was very important that
when you plug in those values that you
get the original value of the function
and that the partial derivatives of the
approximation also match that of the
function and that could mess things up
because once you start plugging in x
naught and y naught over here
that might actually mess with the value
so we're basically going to do the same
thing we did with the linearization
where we put in every time we have an x
we kind of attach it we say x minus x
not just to make sure that we don't mess
things up when we plug in x naught so
instead instead of what i had written
there
what we're going to add as our
quadratic approximation is some kind of
constant and we'll fill in that constant
in a moment times
x minus
x naught
squared
and then we're going to add
another constant multiplied by x minus
x naught
times y
minus y naught
and then that times yet another constant
which i'll call c
multiplied by
y
minus
y naught
squared all right this is quite a lot
going on this is a heck of a function
and these are three different constants
that we're going to try to fill in
to figure out what they should be to
most closely approximate the original
function f now the important part of
making this x minus x naught and y minus
y naught is that when we plug in here
when we plug in you know x naught for
our variable x and when we plug in y
naught for our variable y
all of this stuff is just going to go to
0 and it's going to cancel out and
moreover when we take the partial
derivatives all of it's going to go to 0
as well and we'll see that in a moment
maybe i'll just actually show that right
now
or rather i think i'll call the video
done here and then start talking about
how we fill in these constants in the
next video so i will see you then